hello everyone
welcome to rational science directly
from frankfurt germany
uh we have a good show today and as
we've been doing lately we divide it up
in three parts for those of you who are
new
here and we start with extinction
pretty popular subject
then we continue with physics today
we're going to be dealing with
recoilless emission whatever that is
and then i'm going to be answering some
questions and comments that
people made since last time okay so
let's get on with it the other day
i was telling people that i almost
canceled the class
because i had a pain in one of my
teeth it was quite bad i had that for
two days
and i was able to give the class because
i put a
an aspirin next to it and that's solved
the problem
to a good degree and fellow says there
says they have herbal rubs for your gums
and amazon for uh
pain coconut oil pulling might work
uh well i didn't have to do any of those
what happened was i went to the dentist
and he uh he went in there
and uh opened up some something my gum
i guess at the teeth not my gum but
something in my
teeth and uh my tooth and he uh
put some dentist poison there to uh
i guess uh put the nerve to sleep or
something close it up
and he told me to come next week he's
gonna pull the nerve out
so uh that's i guess the solution
but the uh funny the thing is that when
i was down there i was thinking about
extinction and i'm saying what's gonna
happen
for with those people who survive the
upcoming extinction there's going to be
pockets i think everywhere
on earth where people will survive
groups etc
and will they have dennis
on board or they're gonna you know if
you get a
toothpick you're gonna end up like this
guy um in the movie who uh
castaway or marooned or whatever the
movie was called
where he had to break his uh tooth with
a stone
so uh yeah you don't want to be caught
after the
the extinction event the collapse
essentially the economic collapse
you don't want to be out there and not
have a doctor see
we have we're so used to these things
you have a pain or something well you go
to the dentist you get a doctor you know
i had an
operation a couple years ago now uh on
my prostate
and uh man and even pulled a
stone out of there and uh so that's uh
pretty heavy stuff a pretty heavy uh
operation and uh you know
imagine the end of the world you don't
have any doctors
you can't imagine how the neanderthals
you know when they ran into trouble
broken foot or whatever or maybe a
toothache
how did they handle that anyways uh
think about that
uh you you need to be befriending a
doctor for the end of the
world okay okay uh
i talked about uh google and they've
been fined by
france 600 million dollars
okay and google was not very happy about
that
and someone says according to the
government the problem with google
isn't that they're an evil multinational
new world order apparatus it's at the
old school
multinational nwo apparatus
isn't getting so much of the media
dollar anymore your best
interests are never at heart yeah i
think the issue
with uh the real issue is whether
we should tax the multinationals at a
higher rate
because right now with this covet thing
a lot of people
you know don't have uh income
they lost their jobs and you know if the
government doesn't collect from them
it's got to collect from someone else
and it's probably going to be from these
big corporations which are
making a killing in fact and so
you know the question is whether they
should be
shouldering a heavier load at this point
and again will that stop the collapse
where we're go headed towards as i say
[Music]
no it just may stretch a little more a
little less
but i think the um collapse of the
global economy
is assured and i don't think we can
avoid it
okay talking about neanderthals uh one
fellow says
wow i've suspected that much of the
neanderthal hypocrisy was
distant a distant shot
on the out of africa model i guess they
are removing all suspicions and just
coming
out and saying it okay and another
fellow along the same lines
talking about you know the otto of
africa
he says says if men came out of africa
it probably was not to find
food because that's what i'm saying
you know crow magnet came from africa
came over to
europe and was able to enter europe once
the neanderthals were gone
okay so that's my take on that and he's
saying they probably didn't come out for
food
okay so what did they come out for so
they probably just got tired of
african behavior like we see in south
africa
and other parts of africa we see today
the behavioral differences between
africans and europeans can be seen
pretty clearly
in south africa for example yeah the
problem is people
uh extrapolate what we have today
to the past you know like the other day
one fellow said that the neanderthals uh
he could not imagine that nandeth all
not raping a woman out there
uh they're thinking of in terms of what
they see today
the question here is whether in the wild
in the wild in the wild
um you know a neanderthal would sleep
with someone
that is not of his own species
us we were not of the same species so
first you got to tackle the
issue of species and then you got to
tackle the issue of in the wild
and this is something similar the fellow
is saying that behavioral differences
i don't think uh they care too much
about behavior in those days they were
con
you're talking about the paleolithic
fellow uh
you know you're talking about people who
are living at subsistence
level out there in the jungle they have
to kill something to live one more day
this is what's on their mind okay and uh
yeah they do have sex but hopefully with
the right
species okay but um
you know uh it's very simple uh
humans came out of africa and went
throughout went all the way to asia
to china and indonesia and also went
into europe because we do find
footprints and we have a uh skull
partial skull bone that i showed the
other day female
about 400 000 years ago
they think it's heidelberg heidelberger
heidelbergensis uh
type okay and so
you know there was someone already in
england 400 000 years ago we
we already have evidence that there's
been a
bipedal uh animal
monkey gorilla us whoever
800 000 years ago in england and so
we're finding these
bones these fossils these skulls
and other bones as well right uh in
western
europe and they date to you know 800 000
million years ago maybe so we have to
think that
you know uh at least um
homo erectus which is that level
was it already in england or in france
or germany in that region
and where did he come from well you have
to assume that he came
out of africa okay he had to come out of
africa
and this is the reason uh here you see
the skulls that we have today
homo habilis he's two and a half million
years ago
he's got only 600 cubic centimeter
capacity in his brain and you can see
how the brain grew over time
and we only find a habilis in africa
erectus we find them in different parts
of the world but more of them
in africa and we have to assume that
someone in the level of hobbyists if it
if it wasn't populist himself
someone uh around that level uh gave
birth to erectus eventually
erectus gave birth to heidelberg in
europe
and you would have to think that
heidelberg gave birth to neanderthal
in europe that's uh what see
what the fossil evidence seems to show
okay
so this is my take on that there is no
no uh level of hobbies anywhere
at least we haven't found any in the in
the world yet other than in africa
and uh you know you might say uh well
you know maybe they haven't found it
they haven't looked deep enough or maybe
we'll find a hobbyist level in
china tomorrow or whatever could be but
right now the evidence shows that
habitus
started in africa there is no habitus
outside of africa
that level of development okay
of skull development so we have to think
that
uh our species
at least you know the our whole dynasty
if you want to call it that
uh started in africa
yes that's my take on it anyways uh
fellow also says
um also we can look at the cold ice
records because i was talking that you
know
neanderthals did not wear clothes
because they were born in the snow they
were born in the art in
in arctic weather they didn't know what
cold was
that was my argument last time this guy
picks up on that and says uh
we can look at cold ice records of
william hoff
he's talking about really will hoff uh
not william hoff that's not his name his
name is will hoff
okay the iceman the human tolerance for
cold might be
much greater than we think well uh
there's a difference between mr wilhoff
this is him by the way
let me show you who this man is okay
they put him in ice okay the iceman and
they throw all kinds of ice in there
okay and
the guy can withstand maybe two hours of
this
okay so uh
he's he's uh he does this uh
to disperse his propagate his or
uh proselytize on his method okay he's
got
i guess he's got a business in which he
tries to get people to think in terms of
how they can withstand
extreme cold okay so he does these
shows freak shows barnum and bailey type
free shows and uh it's interesting here
you see uh his method okay uh he talks
about
breathing and cold therapy okay
and it's interesting that uh while
looking at this
i was seeing that uh he goes out into
the cold
and he goes out there with shoes i mean
he he does have
shorts on right but he does wear shoes
okay
and i think that the main reason he wore
shoes is that
maybe he can stay in the snow in the
cold with his
bare feet for a little while
i don't think he can stay there all day
with his feet
in the cold especially if he's not
running that's another
issue you know if you're sweating
because you're running even though it's
cold
and it's in the snow you can withstand
it a lot more than if you're just
standing still
you know on the snow and
i'm saying that all that is completely
completely different than what
neanderthal was
this is neanderthal taking a bath you
know
in the uh winter cold in the snow
he could stay in there forever you know
neanderthal
uh was like the woolly mammoth
willie mammoth didn't use clothes uh
polar bears don't use clothes today
wolves don't use clothes
penguins don't use clothes they have
their feet showed this the other day
their
duck feet completely in the snow
and they're so used to because they live
in the snow
this fellow here will uh huff he he
can't do that
and again he's got to prepare he's got
to train him mentally and physically to
withstand all this stuff he can
do it more he can withstand it for
longer periods than other people
common men out there who haven't
practiced or whatever
we're not talking about the same thing
we're talking about a guy who was born
who's got it in his jeans
who probably was a woolly guy like that
guy there
and who lived in the snow he had no
reason to wear clothes
okay so clothes were not invented by
neanderthals and again
we haven't found needles in any of their
sites we found all kinds of tools
weapons uh different things that we
found from them but
we haven't found any needles you would
think that you know they would have to
sew
uh the garments together the furs or
whatever they
they were supposed to put on no these
were gorillas and any more than a
gorilla puts clothes on in the
african jungle you know these fellows
never had to use clothes at all
okay so uh and that would have been a
distinguishing
feature if humans met them
because humans moving into that region
i'm sure they started putting on clothes
and that's what you see
really that about thirty five thousand
years ago thirty six maybe thirty eight
thousand years ago about two thousand
years after the neanderthals disappeared
which is around forty 000 years ago
humans came in and they started and we
have some evidence that there were
needles
so the needle appears you know maybe
around that time
uh and that that wouldn't strike me as
odd
but for a neanderthal to find to find a
needle
in the neanderthal haystack uh good luck
with that one i don't think it'll ever
happen
okay uh now the fella says uh linear
regression
he's quoting an article here by the way
and he said linear regression
of genetic complexity on a long scale
extrapolated back to just one base pair
suggests
the time of the origin of life 9.7
billion years ago
um and you might say well what's the
problem with that well the problem
uh in when we contrast that with the
official version the earth is only 5
billion
years old okay so these guys are
extrapolating
they're doing just some math there and
they're saying that
it's almost 10 billion years ago that
life started on earth
and so where does that leave the origin
of the earth itself okay
did life start without the earth uh
so he says life before the earth okay
he's suggesting
life came from abroad not necessarily
from
the et's coming here and visiting us in
a way yes in a way no
he's talking about panspermia okay that
some kind of life
eventually arrived on earth but life
already was out there in the universe
maybe before that but it says the word
uh uh this file just makes a comment
says they worded as
uh extrapolated instead of predicted in
this case on tour
uh the solar system with okay he's just
mentioning the place
uh in other words he's saying that
they're just doing math
and that's true you know one thing is
just to
to do math um
we have a lot of problem with that
because they they take a lot of the
physical interpretations they
extrapolate them from math
and that doesn't always work so neatly
okay for mother nature especially mother
nature who doesn't know
anything about math okay
so here when you go to that site the one
he mentioned the the
paper i went in there and looked at it
says these are the main points they want
to make in their paper
life took approximately 5 billion years
to reach the complexity of bacteria okay
there was no sign of intelligent life
in our universe prior to the origin of
earth intelligent life he's qualifying
that he's not saying there was life but
not intelligent life okay
intelligent life has begun appearing in
our universe
has just begun okay thus earth could not
have been deliberately seated with life
by intelligent aliens earth was seated
by panspermia
now there was some kind of bug crawled
out of a rock
and that's how he became um impregnated
with life here on earth that's what he's
suggesting
okay talks about the drake equation for
uh guesstimating the number of
civilizations in the universe
is likely wrong he's saying that drake
had it wrong frank drake
i'll go over that in a second the
doubling of time of complexity has
reached
uh approximately 20 years the predicted
technology
singularity talks about the this paper
talks about that as well
so um the the authors of this paper
they're talking about panspermia the
drake equation which has to do with
um what
how many how what how many uh what the
possibility
is of life being popular
out there in the universe how many
[Music]
civilizations could there be out there
with life that's what the drake equation
tries to figure out
and again it's all mathematics and the
question is
can you extrapolate that into physics
and say oh yeah i can
safely say the following because of that
math
and you know a lot of people criticize
the drake equation on that basis that
it all amounts to your assumptions what
assumptions you make for each one of the
points that drake has
in his equation and so here's the drake
equation
okay um sensei this is what drake
was trying to figure out or what he
suggests are the important points that
anyone tackling the problem
should address okay rate of star
creation in our galaxy
fraction of those stars that have
planets okay
now i would think that all stars have
planets they're saying that they
probably don't and that we got to look
at the fraction of stars that have
planets okay
average number of planets that might
support life per star that
has planets not all planets are
suitable for life okay fraction of the
above that actually go on to develop
life because even if they can maybe they
don't
for whatever uh environmental reasons
right
fraction of the above that develops
intelligent life
uh sometimes i wonder how much how much
intelligence all these people have right
fraction of the above revealing their
existence
via signal release into space in other
words even though they develop life do
they develop the capacity to
transmit and receive that kind of thing
you know information
lifetime of such a civilization wherein
it communicates its signals into space
okay because then they might want to but
maybe their civilizations
dies too early maybe extinction
reaches them for whatever reason and so
they don't get to communicate
even though they have the tools to be
able to do so okay
so that's what the drake equation uh
talks about
here are his values this is what he
calculated drake
uh try to calculate uh what percentage
or how many stars there could be out
there that have life
or planets that have star uh
life and he says one star formed per
year
on the average over the life of the
galaxy that that's the
he addresses point by point there in
other words one-fifth to one-half of all
stars formed will have planets
stars with planets will have between one
and five planets capable of developing
developing life 100 of these planets
will develop
life 100 of which will develop
intelligent life
and 10 to 20 of which will be able to
communicate
i'm not sure why he made that
distinction but then he moves on to the
last when he says
a thousand to a hundred million
communicative civilizations that's what
he thinks
okay that's that's what he thinks uh
should be out there
uh is he maybe a little too optimistic
okay i think sometimes these fellows
again do a lot of math
and they don't pay attention to the
physics of it
okay and what i'm referring to here is
that all these folks
a lot of them in this case uh drake he
had a phd he spent his
entire life on this seti thing
which he worked with carl sagan as well
to send uh
some some evidence that we're alive here
on earth
out into space with one of the probes
uh you know the question is is there any
possibility whatsoever
of ever seeing or receiving information
from another civilization
and the answer is no there is no
possibility whatsoever
these people are wasting their time
wasting money out there
trying to locate some sounds
it's like they don't know physics they
studied physics and they don't know
physics
they know anything about it all they do
is math and extrapolate it from the math
there is absolutely no possibility
whatsoever receiving
uh information from any other
civilization
are there out there yeah i'm almost sure
there have to be in
in the universe with so many planets and
stars and that they're out there
but life is uh is a very scarce resource
and you can tell that just by looking at
our solar system
we're the only planet developed life and
all the others are dead star
dead planets something they're really i
said it right there are dead stars
that's what they are
but uh they didn't develop life and
you would think that with uh
that life should be very common out
there
and it's not if they looked at
like 20 light years in the vicinity
radius
none of the stars seem to have a life of
any kind that they
we haven't received any information or
anything from
those stars from those regions you say
why could that be so
and i'll tell you why but the first one
is that
um you know we've been around only 200
000 years here
on earth us humans and
we've had technology to communicate
maybe for only 150 years at the most
before that we had no way of
communicating anything we had no
notion of the light signals or
electricity or
magnetism in such a way that we could
send information out of the earth we
only had that
type of uh technology only 150 years
now 200 000 years supposedly the
time we've been on earth humans have
been on earth that's a drop of water
in the billions of years that even
general relativity says we've been
around we've been around 14 billion
years according to them
i'm saying we've been around forever
there's been no
beginning to the universe so
here we are 200 000 years is nothing
and that's when we were just hunter
gatherers for most of that time
we developed technology to be able to
communicate
outside the earth maybe 150 years
ago i'll give you 200 years if you want
200 years that's even a smolder that's
not even a drop of water in the ocean
that's
absolutely nothing and now
look at the the fact that we could be
staggered
there's a civilization rising here
it dies it goes away it becomes extinct
and then suddenly we come up
and we look around we say oh let's let's
look for see if there's a civilization
out there that can hear us
and see us well not only are we
separated by
time we're separated by the scarcity
of life to begin with it's got to be
maybe the third planet
third rock from the from the star so to
speak they got to be in the right place
at the right
time then even if it develops
uh a civilization we're talking maybe
150 years
in which they develop technology like we
did here
and then we become extinct and so
even if i mean to match 150 years of
their civilization with 150 years of our
civilization
in the universe it's almost impossible
i would say it's it's so scarce it's
it's beyond
calculations i'm sure a mathematician
will go out there and try to figure it
out but
it's it's uh it's not even probable it's
impossible
so the question is staggering staggering
in
development all civilizations come to an
end extinction so this notion that
they developed that there's all these
levels that civilization takes over
the planet then over the star then over
the galaxy and so on
absolute nonsense absolutely nonsense
these people
see too much star trek and they're not
thinking
enough time right okay uh
one follower tries to address the
question that i ask always at the end
which is answer to the question why the
animals in the sea
approximately died when the land animals
died because the sea animals were the
food
pyramid of the land animals or maybe
vice versa
and when one went the other when one
went the other
one went too so uh
the dinosaurs ate fish huh
no i don't think so uh i like the fact
that give it a try at least but
uh at least i won't go with this theory
i don't think that's what happened now
the uh again the mosasaurs they ate
ammonites which ate um
probably zooplankton or or both just
plankton of any kind
and uh not of any kind they ate of
special kind
and it was the kind that disappeared
another plankton came up
like the grasses came um
at the end of from the middle of the
cretaceous towards the end of the
cretaceous
you know the the angiosperms covered the
land
they displace the conifers and some
somewhat like that what you have in the
seas is the same thing the small
plankton replaced the big plant
plankton and the ammonites take plankton
the big plankton
the ones they were used to and what ate
them were the moses ours
uh that's when just one food chain just
just for reference
and so i don't think any of those were
involved with the
land dinosaurs t-rex's and whatever
now one had nothing to do with the other
okay so no i don't uh subscribe to this
fellow's uh
theory but nice try okay
uh one quotes
several uh different papers
and they all say essentially the same
thing that
none of the dinosaurs ate angiosperms
okay so he just put three uh
references saying that none of them ate
angiosperms
they all ate conifers there is no
evidence that end that
dinosaurs ate angiosperms i read one
paper once i think it was from an indian
fellow
and this argued that he found
coprolites or i can't remember really
what but he had
evidence that one dinosaur at least
eight
uh angiosperms and again he was
criticized by
a lot of his peers i don't think we
really have any evidence
that dinosaurs ate angiosperms i don't
think we'll ever have
that evidence and people were are going
to try to stretch
the evidence that they see or
interpreted in such a way as to
fit the angiosperms into the mouths of
dinosaurs because that would be a big
hit
you know he'd get his name in lights i
don't think he'll ever find that because
again
dinosaurs radiated with the conifers
and here they were around for millions
of years not only in the jurassic but
then again
in the cretaceous and towards the end
when the
conifers were dying out in the last half
of the cretaceous
maybe 60
million years uh they
gradually were going away
all the conifers and they were replaced
by the angiosperms
which is what the mammals grew or
radiated with
so uh i think that's that's really what
happened
the angiosperms muscled aside the
conifers
which meant that the dinosaurs because
they ate
conifers were muscled aside as well only
because the forests were shrinking
the jungles were shrinking jungles of
cycads
cycad likes william sonjas and other
types of plants that they ate
those were disappearing the forest the
jungles were becoming smaller and
smaller
and the ground was being taken over by
these weeds
which is what we eat today the
angiosperms
you know that's that's a better solution
to extinction than
um than uh saying that you know
uh an asteroid hit the earth okay
okay um and
along the same line fell says yeah it
looks uh
he says that looks that these people are
trying to prove it at all costs
that you know the dinosaurs ate
angiosperms but they have no way of
proving it
they found no evidence so far but what
they
a lot of people are noticing in the
paleontology
world is that what it says there the new
work helps confirm
another recently published and
controversial claim that
most dinosaurs were already in decline
40 million years before
the meteorite struck and finished them
off
yeah i don't think there was a meteorite
or asteroid
that finished them off has nothing to do
at all whatsoever with the extinction of
the dinosaurs
the dinosaurs were already underway out
and it was a gradual disappearance and
if you're going to talk about a gradual
disappearance
well i think a good bet is that um
plants were going away plants that they
ate
dinosaurs cannot change at the last
moment and say oh i'm going to switch
over to angiosperms because i cannot
find enough
conifers it doesn't happen
in the wild okay especially if you've
got millions of years
of conditioning to a certain type of
food
millions of years dynasties after
dynasties after dynasties
and the last dynasty says oh i can't
find conifers i think i'll start eating
magnolias or roses
it doesn't happen again rabbits don't
switch overnight from lettuce to pine
leaves okay
they don't like them and i don't think
you would either but you tried
you showed us the experiment do the
experiment you say tomorrow i'm not
gonna eat tomato i'm not gonna eat
lettuce i'm not gonna eat any of that
stuff i'm gonna start eating pine leaves
yeah show us
okay again final
always try to do extinction 101 before
102
101 is mass extinctions of the past
okay then you can always move on to uh
human extinction
because if you can figure out the how it
happened in the past and how the animals
died in the past
maybe you can extrapolate that mechanism
to us today and find out whether we
can overcome that same mechanism whether
our intelligence
our technology our ability to foresee
events and take action whether that has
anything to do whether that is an
antidote to extinction
well you can do something about
extinction and i'm saying we cannot
okay and again the
good question here is this one the key
extinction question
why do the animals on land disappear
more or less
at the same time as the animals
in the seas that's the question
uh you really gotta answer okay
and again if you can answer that it'll
give you a pretty good clue
as to why these
animals
disappeared and if you can figure that
out you can probably
figure out how they became extremely
extrapolate that mechanism to us
that's why i like that question and i
think it's a key question
okay let's move around to the physics
part
and we're going to be doing what we're
going to do in
uh recoilless recoilless emission
whatever that is
okay here's a quick recap of what we did
these weeks and we've looked at quantum
mechanics the mysterious
unexplained that's why they're
mysterious they're mystical right
properties and we talked about the
coherence okay
that like for example in the slit
experiment
the the particles would not would be in
phase
all along or the wave would be in phase
but it re interacts with the environment
and because of that it goes out of phase
and that's
that decoherence phenomenon that they've
noticed in the lab can they explain it
no they can't they just say
it is so entanglement one particle over
here
affects another one over there one far
away from the other
how do they do that they don't know they
can't explain it they just say
it does so it's a it's a fact okay
superposition one particle vibrates the
other one doesn't vibrate it's the same
particle how can one particle vibrate
and not vibrate at the same time
can you explain it they say no we can't
it is so
god ordained it is so that's what
happens these are the explanations they
give you these are
all the physical interpretations the
names for each of those physical
interpretations
shortly there's cat the cat is both dead
and alive until you peek
inside the box it's got to do all of
these essentially have to do with
dualities
uh the mathematicians love dualities
because it
in a way it helps them uh cover every
base
they can say well why this well this is
because of a and whether
that's because of b but a is a
contradiction of b but they use both
simultaneously and they call that
duality and they love these things
okay complementarity life light is both
a particle and a wave they say it
behaves
that's the same thing because when you
say it behaves as such
you are in in essence simulating
here is a particle and here is a wave
okay so they're saying
depending on the experiment that you run
that's the way they
uh sweep it under the rug the problem no
the problem is you cannot say that light
is both
a particle and a wave and that when
you measure you do something it it
collapses to one or the other you can't
do that
not in science maybe in religion
uncertainty
uh the ball stands still and when it
stands still you know very little about
its motion
and when it's moving you know very
little about it's standing still it's
location right again dualities
contradictory dualities okay and they
they they love these things you know
they say it gives us something to think
about
spin spin what is the problem with spin
spin is not spin
that's the problem with spin okay spin
is not spin spin is some kind of
orientation of some kind and they
measure at that
it's like chopping light or the electron
at that point and saying oh it's
pointing in that direction
but they use the word spin because they
want to give you the
notion that this thing is twirling
around like a top
and that's what they're going to use
when you say well but is it twirling
around like a top is that what you're
telling me
no it ain't it's standing still we
measure we say that's half spin that's
minus half that's
one that's zero spin they give you all
these numbers
for uh orientations or tilt of the
spin whatever that is so hopefully you
understood it all so all these are
unexplained properties that's all they
are they just say it is so we don't
understand it but
it happens and we can use it for
technology and that's why they use the
word quantum
as an adjective for everything quantum
dot quantum computer
why because they're going to be using
the phenomena which they don't
understand or can't explain
and they're going to use that to say
well we use the effect
in technology in the computer oh yeah
great you can use it it's like saying
i'm gonna use a magnet to pick up uh
iron filing you don't know how it does
it but
i can use that for something you know
because uh here i can use a
magnet to pull something out like a car
in a
record uh yard okay so you can pull and
you say okay
i can use it technology can you explain
it oh no
i don't i don't know how how mother
nature does that that's the issue the
issue is that's where you have to break
your brain
because hopefully mother nature doesn't
do these things
with nothing hopefully she does it with
something something which is invisible
and intangible and that's what magnetism
light and gravity that's what all those
are they're invisible and intangible
mediators we can't see them we can't
touch them
and these people hope to see and touch
them by running an experiment in the lab
that's the problem okay okay and today
we're going to do recoilless
recoilless emission what the hell let's
record this emission
okay here's um
seen this maybe somewhere uh when you
look at a crystal lattice
uh any crystal for that matter well you
say it doesn't move
but it does it does to some degree what
they're saying
is that atoms in a crystal lattice do
move
okay so uh you got to think about that
whenever
you're looking at these notions that um
things are solid and they're just
standing still
they're saying no the electrons are
vibrating
and maybe the atoms are vibrating as
well you know so
these things vibrate and that's what
they want to show you
in in general terms that this is even
it's a if it's a solid
it's not standing still remember uh
what is the duality that stands still
while it moves okay
okay um so here we have uh
an example of that which i showed a
couple weeks ago the phonons
okay uh what is a phonon well it's a
bunch of atoms that move in some kind of
way
so they have all these uh
notions these uh phenomena that they
call
phone on the particle sound it gives you
a
a sound of some kind and so they
track it by sound you know we had the uh
what is it the photon is the particle of
light
we had the chrono it's a particle of
time
we have the higgs the particle of mass
and now we have the phonon the particle
of sound
so they've created all these notions out
there can they explain any of them no
they can't they just say they
all these move in the crystal lattice uh
in some way that they can measure that
they can detect
okay uh so so we know that these things
aren't stuck
okay at least this is the theory that
they say you know these atoms these
electrons are moving around they're
vibrating it's not like standing still
even though you got a rock a crystal
that's
looks solid the atoms in there are not
standing still okay or the electrons
okay so that's the starting point and so
what what did moss power
come up with well here it is give me a
second here let me put this up here
okay this was mossbar in 1958 he came up
with it the mossbar
most power effect or recoilless nuclear
resonance fluorescence
is a physical phenomenon discovered by
rudolph
mossbar in 1958 it involves the
resonant and recoil-free okay
emission and absorption of what gamma
radiation
they're going to talk about gamma rays
gamma rays are
high frequency ultra high frequency rays
okay it's important to keep that in mind
by atomic nuclei uh bound in a solid
okay so there is no recoil this image so
even though
there you see them vibrating and so on
and the
light i put it as a wave here goes
outwards
there's no uh the the atom itself
does not recoil at least for the gamma
rays okay that's what he was able to
measure
he got an oval for that okay okay
uh it turns out that um you know
we have this idea that it's more like
this
okay that the atoms are not vibrating
we think of it that way okay and
again we're talking about gamma rays
here okay so it's important to keep that
in mind
talking about very high frequency
uh light
what was this good for well a couple
years later uh we had these
pair of uh people pounding rebca and
they ran the harvard tower experiment
in which they toyed around with this
phenomena
and they were able to prove
what it says they're the last classical
test of general relativity
they were able to verify it okay what
they
saw essentially was that light coming
out of the basement
that's where rebko was going to the
tower at harvard
where pound was uh it had a different
frequency
in that in that in just i think it's
just
three stories high maybe a little more
maybe it's
i don't know how big uh how tall the
tower was
one was in the basement the other guy
was in the tower and what they said the
guy from the bottom shot
the light and the guy in the top um
noticed that the frequency changed each
one measured his own frequency it says
the frequency changed
and the wavelength got longer
essentially okay
lower frequency at the top and so they
said gravity is pulling
on uh light so they confirm that
gravity bends light with that
essentially okay it warps light
and so yeah it's got to do with the it's
the gravitational redshift experiment
redshift meaning again uh it's a
doppler type effect okay whether it's if
it's coming towards you okay
it's a blue shifted it's receding it's
redshifted and so they're saying it's a
redshift experiment the farther uh
light is from you from the source uh
the more red shifted the more the uh
links in the case of the rope are
farther apart in other words the
wavelength
is longer okay or the frequency
is uh lower
okay uh measure the change of frequency
uh of light
moving in a gravitational field okay in
other words the
gravity is pulling on light that's what
they said frequency blue shifted towards
the higher frequency
and test demonstrated the
general relativity prediction that
clocks should run different rates in
different places
of a gravitational field all this as a
consequence
of mr mossbar turns out that mossbar
got his noble but these files did not
which
and they proved uh the last uh classical
thing from general relativity which is
quite interesting you know
they didn't even get a mention well they
did get mentioned but they didn't get on
noble
okay so uh what i like about rudolph
is that he was a professor several
universities in the states and in
germany
he's originally from germany and this is
what he would tell his students
otherwise he wouldn't pass him on the
test he was quite strict with him he
said
explain it explain it
the most important thing is that you are
able to explain it
yeah love it thank you
rudolph rudy i'll call him rudy
you will have exams there you have to
explain it
okay he's gonna he asks his students to
explain it great eventually you pass
them you get your
diploma and you think that's it no the
whole life is an exam
you'll have to write applications you'll
have to discuss with peers
so learn to explain it
you can train this by explaining to your
to another student
a colleague if they are not available
explain it to your mother or to your cat
okay so rudy says you gotta explain it
otherwise
i guess he's saying you're not a
physicist a scientist or whatever
totally in agreement did rudy
explain it i mean he he discovered the
mossbar effect did he explain it
and the answer is no he had no clue why
that was the case why uh the atoms did
not recoil
because you would think that you know
when you shoot a cannon
shoots a ball which is the quantum
version of
how uh light is uh
uh created and expelled from the atom
because light has origin in the atom
well here if you take a cannon and you
shoot it well the cannon will
go backwards and so if the
photon is energy and energy is mass
you would think that uh you know there's
this
recoil and mr boswar says
no there ain't but he cannot explain why
there is no
recall he just says it is so it's
another one of those it is so
discoveries of quantum okay uh the first
problem that
uh mr mossvar
had to in other words the first thing he
should have explained really
is why uh we have springs you know these
uh notions that all atoms are
interconnected
and there's like um a spring that's
acting between the atoms
because that's what a lattice is the
crystal that is has atoms
but the atoms are you know separated
from other atoms and there's something
in between them
because they are able to maintain this
rigidity this
more or less rigidity that you see in in
crystals or
rocks or whatever okay metals and uh
here's a testimony from
several sources okay and i want you to
look at this says
one guy disney says but the
electromagnetic theory is not based on
action at a distance as was
newton's space is thought as be as being
threaded throughout with
electrical and magnetic what tensions
whatever tensions are
okay really what he's saying is it's
space is like it's shredded throughout
next guy this is ebby he wrote his
general chemistry
chemical bond acts like a stiff spring
connecting nuclei
as a result the nuclei in a molecule
vibrate rather than maintaining fixed
positions relative to
each other again he got that from uh
essentially uh
from from busbar right
the notion that you know they maintain
fixed positions and there is no recoil
when they shoot out this energy they
call light
a field in physics may be envisioned as
if space were filled with
interconnected vibrating balls and
sprains that's the
casimir effect and then um there was a
paper uh out of this electromagnetic
wave physics 2000 at the
colorado university and the folks right
over there
wiggling one charge causes the field
lines attached to it to wiggle
and after a time the other charge starts
to wiggle
it's just like a rope connecting two
rocks yeah that's what it looks like
that's
that's what these people are describing
two atoms connected by a rope
the wave here consists of wiggling line
of electric force which you can think of
as being
attached to the vibrating charge
i mean how much more evidence do you
want than all this testimony
these people are telling you that atoms
are interconnected
you have to think of them as if
as if well now why not go the whole
you know mile and say well what if they
are
interconnected physically interconnect
because they never identified what they
say
interconnects them that acts like a
stiff spring
that vibrates etc etc
what are they talking about what is that
thing that they say that you have to
assume
as that it's there as if they were
connected
they're all saying the same thing
they're threaded throughout
it's like two rocks connected by a
spring or
or whatever what are they talking about
what is that entity that connects the
two rocks the two atoms the two
whatevers
and you know again they they do the math
they say uh
like in the case of entanglement this
particle here affects that one over
there
the math is great no problem they
measured they
they've got it down pat but can they
tell you what that physical entity
that's sending the message to the other
particle is they never identified it
is there such a monster in quantum
mechanics
no the answer is no you can look up the
standard model you won't find that
mediator even mention it's not
that's when they talk when they give you
the physical interpretation they throw
that in there and say
assume that it's as if but you don't see
it anywhere
and so that's what you have to ask them
say well what is this thing that
interconnects the atoms
that vibrates that does all this stuff i
mean if it vibrates hopefully it's a
physical object
right what's vibrating uh concept
okay it turns out that they had uh an
answer for many years already comes from
mr einstein
okay einstein wrote in 1905 his paper
you know it's his uh paper is on the
electrolytic
dynamics of moving bodies okay
and what did i need say well he said
light is
always propagated in empty space with
what
a definite velocity little c there okay
which is independent of the state of
motion
of the emitting body
he's saying that light is independent of
the motion
of the source and again you've heard of
that
maybe uh where a train what happens if
you turn your flashlight or or
your car your car's driving down the
road you turn the flashlight
should you add the speed of the car to
the to the light
and the answer is no but einstein could
not explain it
again he could only tell you it is so
that's mathematical physics for you they
describe they tell you it is so
and we can predict that it's going to
happen again and again and again yeah
great
so far we have a description tell me why
what's
causing that see under the rope there's
no problem because you're moving
through the rope through the ropes many
gazillions
you're moving through let's talk about
one one atom is moving
one hydrogen atom is moving through the
robe and the rope
is uh forking out at the electron shell
and going over and
forming part of that shell momentarily
and then continues going so
what you have is a bubble made of uh
threads and one thread the one from that
specific rope is going around
the atom so the atom can never touch the
rope it's just going through it
and that's why when it pumps back and
forth
giving signals along the rope
it's not adding its velocity to the rope
it's just
whatever
[Music]
expansion and contraction it does that's
what's going to determine what the
frequency
or link length of the rope is it's got
nothing to do whatsoever
with it pushing the rope which is what
people think
when they're saying if i turn the
flashlight on while i'm on that train or
in my car so yeah
you don't add the speed to the
to the signal called light
because the threads the two threads that
form the rope go around
the atom as the atom moves through along
the rope
okay just like sliding beads on an
abacus
does the bead push
the wire along which it's sliding and
the answer is no and so no you don't add
the speed
uh of light to
the motion of the source and he never
figured it out
he said it is so but he could not
explain
why the physical cause of that okay
okay so uh what's the issue the issue is
that um
here's uh here's again uh
mossbar's recoilless emission we're
saying that the atoms are not moving in
this case
as gamma rays come out of there
how do we do it in uh under the rope
model here you have it side by side
okay we have it with a rope okay
so the atom does not have to move at all
if you move that uh let's assume that's
a cube
a crystal of some kind if you move it
it's just going to eat into the rope
it's going to slide along the rope it's
not going to
push the rope in other words okay
and why uh is
again the the
frequency of light the same
it doesn't change well here you i think
i've explained this in the past
here you see it that
what you have is that all you're
changing
as the atom is expanding and contracting
what it does it just
torques the rope at different rates by
doing so
you know the rope does not have um
any chance of going faster all you can
do
is change the frequency for the
wavelength in this case the link length
okay so there you see eight links for
example in the top one
and if the atom is pumping slower then
you're gonna have four links
and if it's pumping faster you're gonna
have 16 links
what changes well the rope is the length
of the rope the physical entity
that mediates light is the same in all
cases you have the same
one meter or whatever amount of rope
what changes is just the number of links
produced
by that amount of rope
threads so this is this is the
uh answer to einstein's first
einstein's question but it also answers
mossbar's question of why there is no
recoil there's no recoil because there
is no
push okay especially for gamma rays it
turns out that
these people um they
they are not able to
measure exactly the gamma ray so
the party line today is that
well we can't measure so much at that uh
frequency and so what
they say that essentially there's no
recoil because they cannot really
measure at that level okay
and so they do a mathematical
calculation and that's it
but again they have no physical
interpretation for
their calculation or for their
measurement they don't know why that's
the case
okay so this is where we have
differences with these folks
okay what are the conclusions let me go
through them here
uh record this emission is just another
unjustified discovery
of quantum mechanics they have
discoveries they have no explanations
none none whatsoever mossbar never
identified the springs
that vibrate between atoms and holds
them together in the crystal lattice
but what is that thing what is that
spring that holds two atoms together or
that keeps them apart or whatever
they never identify that they just say
you have to make
uh believe that it's there it's like
it's
as if it were there
not just say it is there okay because
you can't see and touch it is that the
reason
moshbar never explained what causes the
effect named after him
okay he never could explain the moss bar
effect he just described it he says it
is so
i say i never explained why light speed
is independent of the movement of the
source
okay so we have uh all all these
unexplanations
no one can explain what he discovered
they all get nobles they all get their
names and lights but not one of them can
explain
what's going on okay and the rope model
emerges
mossbar effect with einstein's principle
of relativity which is the
you know constancy of the speed of light
and
light always torques at the same speed
along the electromagnetic road
why because frequency is inversely
proportional to
the length of the link you make the
links
smaller i always show that in my rope
let me get this one out of here
here you have a rope okay and the more
you target
the more links you have the less you
target the longer the links and the
fewer links you have
that's why the speed of light is a
constant always
okay in every situation
and that's why we have recoiled this
emission and that's why
einstein could not add the speed of
light
to the movement of the source because he
was thinking
push and he could not explain why
it wouldn't be so why you don't have to
add it and the answer is that
the atom goes right along and slides
through the rope so it has no reason to
push it and it doesn't
okay so uh
there you have an idea on uh mr mossbar
and his
his effect which he could not explain
okay moving on here let's move on to the
questions and
comments that people made fellow says uh
do a video on the modern transistor and
how companies teach
uh test each of the one billion
individual transistors
well they don't really test uh
they test certain bus lines etc okay but
i think the main one is uh you know how
it works how uh
transistor works and we're not
interested in technology here
we try to answer the
scientific questions and scientific
questions are explanations of mechanisms
and there's already a video out there
uh several videos really that
uh show you how uh transistors work
okay look that title up transistors how
do they work and you'll find good
explanations
of how these transistors work the one on
top is a bipolar the one on the bottom
is an mos
i work with both technologies started
out with bipolar work my way up to
mos metal oxide semiconductor and
yeah i mean you'll you'll find the
explanation how they work
the important thing that you have to
keep in mind is something else
this is this is what's important at
least if you're going to watch these
videos this is what you got to keep in
mind
and that's here's the silicon lattice
okay
and what you have is this is just pure
silicon assuming it's
not contaminated in any way and what you
have is
and we're going to use the quantum
version here so that i don't
take you to the complexity of the rope
model
well we're just going to use their their
model because
for what we need to explain here it's
fine you have four
electrons on the outer shells okay and
so when you have
four other atoms around you you have all
those uh
outer shells completely covered with
eight electrons which is what they say
is needed for it to be saturated and so
silicon is just
all saturation no problem it does
it's a semiconductor because of that
it's uh it doesn't conduct electricity
uh how do you get it to conduct
electricity then well
you have to do something to it you have
to dope it it's called doping
either usually the typical ones are
boring and phosphorous
phosphorus is negative because it has an
extra electron
and boron has one fewer electron that's
why it's
called positive okay one uh one has five
which is
uh boron and boron has three in its
outer shell
okay so if you put phosphorous into the
silicon lattice
there's gonna be one electron that
doesn't know where to go and supposedly
that's the one that's going to drift and
cause the electrical properties
and if you put boron what you have is
you're introducing holes
you're introducing the absence of an
electron known as a hole
and now you have current because this
electron goes to try to fill that hole
but it leaves a hole behind and so that
you have the movement of holes in the
opposite direction
of the electron flow that's the theory
okay
and so here you see it you see boron and
phosphorus okay
phosphorus at the top you can see it's
got an extra electron which i
marked in red okay and so it tends to
move around
okay boron on the other hand it's
missing one uh
electron in its outer shell i put
a little circular elongated circle there
to show that you know it's
it's missing that uh electron
and you can see that they they have a
different
the the atom itself has a different
structure the ones on the right are the
structures that we propose under the
rope model okay
and chemistry uses those calls them
balloons well
they don't call balloon they call them
orbitals they call them
energy levels no they are balloons
they are physical balloons but chemistry
never figured that out because
quantum mechanics says that that's just
a little bead going around
no those are balloons and that's exactly
the model that we have
in under the rope model okay so
what you're seeing there is the real
mccoy okay
okay give me a second here
another question first asked
says no need for parallel universes use
a torus link of two threads to qualify
existence the issue here is the word
exist
what do does the threat exist the single
thread that we have in
under the rope model does that exist and
the only way we can get it to exist if
there's another thread
another universe parallel universe out
there that
um is in which none of the atoms of that
universe are connected to any of the
atoms in
our universe okay so then we can say
that
our threat exists because there's
another thread nearby and all we have to
have for
for existence is location location what
is it
set of distances and here we have a
distance between the two threads
okay so he says a thread turns into our
universe by playing cat's cradle and
crossing over itself skillions of time
to make atoms
this is not possible with a thread loop
after you twine it into a rope
okay a twine thread loop has two ends
and and cats cradle possible
no no no cats cradle possible if you
insist on using a single thread then use
a
taurus knot which is functionally the
same thing well uh cascado's a game
that people play there try to make
patterns with those
uh strings or threads or whatever and i
think this guy got his fingers tied up
there
tied up in knots um
i don't think he got it right uh i think
you can do it with a single
um thread okay
we don't need to do any of this that he
talked about i'm not sure what he's not
understanding
um here's my version okay here's a
twisted um thread closed loop thread
it's a rubber band okay and that's a
picture i took
here's the real mccoy let me get this
one out of here
okay here's the real mccoy i did that
one i just took a picture of that so you
can see that it's possible to take a
rubber band
closed loop thread right and twirl it
into a uh a rope okay
and it's closed loop in other words um
you can do if the thread is big enough
whole universe uh
you know you can move around from one
point all through that thread
everywhere you go through the atoms
through the ropes
and eventually arrive at your starting
point
so i'm not sure what this fellow is not
understanding why he needs two threads
first of all i don't understand that
what his problem is i really don't can't
understand
his problem okay um
fellow asked question he says uh do
light
does light bend around other heavy
objects not only stars can you explain a
little more about this bending
does mass have anything to do with it at
all and the answer is uh
right there in front of you it's really
very simple you just have to understand
what relativity is proposing which is
mass a concept it's like weight
and you put weight on top of a canvas
which is not a canvas which is
space-time which is a concept
so you put the concept weight on a
concept called space-time and you bend
it
that's what these people are saying
we're done that's it for
general relativity if you wanted to know
the relativity theory there it is
that's all there is don't look beyond
that that's all there
is that's the theory of relativity they
say it's uh they're equations but
equations are not theories equations are
descriptions
theories are explanations that's the
explanation they give
so that's the end of general relativity
right there they have one concept
bending another concept
how do we do it you know you got to look
at it as a roulette there you know the
little ball going around in circles and
that's essentially what they're saying
that the earth does around the sun
it moves around a roulette uh
a canvas that was created by the weight
of the sun
on that canvas how do we do it we say
much simpler
you troll around the sun twirls the
earth around
at the end of gazillions of threads that
ropes
we're done that's it essentially here it
is i show it sometimes
that's that's why the earth doesn't fly
out of the sun uh
my fingers are the sun and the the ball
is
the uh earth that's how simple gravity
is
we're done that's that's it and here you
see um
i show the four mechanisms okay uh
to summarize all that essentially you
have particles which is what newton
suggested
okay and you have um
uh you could do it with pressure there
on the right hand side
uh i'm not sure too many people suggest
that
i i'd like to see them form a perfect uh
and constant ellipse elliptical orbit of
the earth
by applying all these particles coming
from everywhere
okay but the ones that
we're comparing really are the two on
the bottom you have workspace which is
what einstein proposed okay and you have
the rope model which is the
every atom on earth is connected to
every atom of the sun
and the sun essentially just twirls the
earth around like a kid would uh twirl a
ball at the end of a string around his
head
and because space is nothing the earth
doesn't have
anything to rub its elbow against
so it can keep doing this forever almost
right so there is no resistance no
friction between the earth and space
and that's why we roll around the sun
that's how simple it is
okay so i'm not sure we need to do much
more on that than
what i just explained if you have any
questions ask me but
that's it it doesn't get any better than
that
okay a fellow asked something about
location he says
what do you mean by location i thought
everybody knew
your distance from every other object in
the universe
and angle well i don't know about the
end angle part
that's not not at all it plays no role
whatsoever
but yeah the distance from every object
in the universe to the
target object and that's what you see
there you see a cube
and you have a distance to every single
object in the universe that's called
location the location of the cube with
respect to all matter in the universe
we're done that's the definition of
location so
i don't know if he agrees with it or or
what but i just wanted to clarify that
that is what
we call location same fellow says
something about squares he said you
can't use the word square
on the subject as the subject of a
sentence
and yeah he's right in physics okay so
in ordinary speech you can use
anything you want but in physics you
cannot use the word square as a subject
of a sense he's totally correct
and the reason is that a square is an
object
that does not exist and physics only
deals
with objects that exist that's why you
can't use it
okay now he says exist means it has to
have location yeah exactly
that's what exists means means that
if it doesn't have location it doesn't
exist and if it doesn't exist it's not a
part of physics
that's irrelevant compared uh with
regard to
the question of what is the definition
of the word object
see what people have done for many years
is confused the word object with the
word exist
they they think it's a synonym and so
this file makes the same error he thinks
that
because a square doesn't exist because
the square doesn't have location
uh you can't you you should not be able
to
use it in physics because it's not an
object
no it's it's an object but it's an
object that does not
exist and physics only deals with
objects that exist
that's the answer to that question okay
okay um
next uh question i think same fell he
comes up there and he says
uh does light have shape or not yes it
does we know
that it's a rope yeah and a rope has
shape
i don't know any rope that does not have
shape this one has shape
i hope you can see it all ropes have
shaped i don't know any rope that does
not have
shape so yeah uh
light has shape but we don't say it that
way we say
that the mediator of light
has shape light is a combination of two
things
the thing and its behavior
the object and what it does the thing
is a rope what it does is torque
and so when we say light we're really
putting both together and saying
light is a rope that torques that's what
light is
okay and actually it's the thumping that
it gives the atom
for example in your eye uh it's that
thumping that sends you the signal to
your brain
through other atoms it's relayed
so yeah light is a rope so a rope has
shape
and uh
and and it exists because it has
location
but uh the the important thing is that
light is a rope but the the correct way
of saying it
is light is mediated by an object and
that object
looks more or less like a robe it has a
rope-like
configuration it looks like dna
okay what it does is torque
okay that's why hopefully light moves
okay there is some motion there
otherwise you know we'd have a static
universe
okay uh foul says
what do you mean torsion is
bi-directional
i twist the clothesline from one end and
so do atoms okay tell me
uh don't do it from the ends you're
getting confused when you do it from the
ends do it from the center
okay now tell me that torsion there that
thing that's twirling around there
uh which way is it going is it going
right or going left
what atom is it stimulating
well i would say stimulus both atoms at
the ends
so yeah this is totally different than
um
what the mathematicians have
uh which is just going in one direction
you know uh the waves come out of the
atom go in one direction
why would they come back and
the particles if you want to do
particles same thing it comes out of the
atom and
goes in one direction this one since it
involves two atoms it interconnects two
atoms
it's a torsion that uh
propagates to both atoms simultaneously
you go to one atom you see it it's it's
torquing there you go to the other
other atom it's also torquing there in
fact from one atom's point of view it's
going clockwise from the other one it's
going counterclockwise
okay so yeah i'm not sure what problem
he has this should be straightforward
okay and final issue here says
why should the amount of links eaten by
an atom during expansion correspond
at all with link length
well the issue here is that i didn't
invent this mother nature invented this
okay
um mr bohr niels bohr
he's the guy who proved if you want to
use that word
1911 that um
you know um photons
uh well let's say it in reverse
that a an electron falls
between energy levels it doesn't fall to
an intermediate energy levels
and that energy level is the is
is the amount of energy of a photon
the amount of energy of a photon under
the rope model is one link
of a given rope okay it's one link
that is your photon that is your energy
and so what we're saying is that when
the atom expands it eats exactly one
link
okay i didn't invent that mother nature
that's like
saying what why is the speed of lights
little c 300 000 kilometers per second
i didn't invent that god invented that
or the devil or one of those guys out
there
you know all we can do is measure and
say yeah that's the speed of light 300
000 and it's a constant then you got to
explain why it's a constant
but why is it specifically
300 000 kilometers per second well maybe
in another universe
that has more matter or you know more
thread or
fewer less thread or whatever they have
a different speed of light in that
universe
that could happen also the speed of
light could be different on the other
side of our universe
i mean i'm i haven't been there i don't
know i can only tell you what's in this
neighborhood and similarly uh
you know all we can say is that if mr
bohr
has it right mathematically right and he
says that
a photon is the amount of a single
photon the
energy of that photon is what determines
the difference between gaps between the
one energy level and another energy
level within which
the electron falls and it doesn't fall
anywhere between those two energy
levels then it's very clear that under
the rope model
you have to eat one rope because that's
what's going to determine
the outer expansion and the inner
expansion and nothing in between
okay so that's the notion there
and with that i'll see you uh on sunday
we'll see you then bye-bye